this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
and we start at five o'clock with that
breaking news after police tell us a
child has died after ingesting illegal
pills good evening to you i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez so let's
get right out to david charns with our
eight news now i-team he's in the
newsroom he's been working the story
throughout the afternoon david and we
are getting some new information 8 news
now confirming a 15-year-old middle
school student in north las vegas died
after overdosing on pills on campus
we're also told several other students
may have overdosed as well but did not
die from this 8 news now i-team sources
say this happened at sedway middle
school that is near gowen in commerce
again sources telling us one child died
after possibly taking these illegal
pills new video here from that school
and we are confirming that teenager is
15 years old this is a topic the i-team
has covered for months now illicit
fentanyl a highly deadly substance just
a tiny amount can kill you may have seen
those signs that say one pill can kill
these are pressed pills that drug
dealers are selling to people especially
to kids now sources telling the eight
news now i-team ccsd is of course
investigating we are working right now
to find out more information we have
crews working this story at the school
and in the neighborhood we'll bring you
update coming up next at 6. for now i'm
david charns live in the newsroom live
local now